build subdivisions move to
Dallas I won't have them here
that's right nothing happens in
this Valley I don't know about
called progress John progress doesn't need
your permission yeah this Valley it does
the hit series Yellowstone has ignited interest
in all things Western and that includes the sport
of cutting where a Horse and Rider work together
to handle cattle now cutting is skyrocketing in
popularity as viewers want a piece of the action
for themselves Janet shamlian has the story
my head here
the hit series Yellowstone is full
of action-packed scenes like this
A Horse and Rider head to head with a
calf in a back and forth test of will
this is the hold on for dear life sport of
cutting things like this on television's
most watched show have given cutting
visibility it's never had then do not need
wow that's a nice horse the thrill of
a ride many now want to try themselves
it feels like you're strapped on a
turbo with a vacuum uh like a missile
Lindy Burch would know a world champion and
among the sports most decorated thank you
Linda we met her at a competition in Fort Worth
Yellowstone has exposed a whole new group of
people to cutting what's that been like it's
like the phone started ringing about what you
know where can I get lessons and I want to ride
a cutting horse the increase has been phenomenal
and that's at The Cutting world on fire
we call it the Yellowstone effect but
the last year and a half two years the
prices have have dramatically increased
Jeremy Barwick is a Wheeler Dealer
in the sport so this is third Edge
he is the current ncha open horse of the Year
Barwick owns this Texas breeding for facility
as well as an auction company selling the world's
top mares and stallions and I wouldn't want people
to think it's only for the very wealthy because
it's not I've seen people buy horses for four and
five thousand dollars they go and win hundreds
of thousands of dollars welcome to my playground
this is Dylan excellent now you're ready to
go Lindy Burke says anyone can learn just
like me back up straight and then you're
going to turn him right over his Hawks
very good there you go and H is no barrier we have
nine-year-olds in the open competing in the open
and we have 85 year olds competing in the open
because the great equalizer is your horse come
competitors have two and a half minutes
the writer is in charge while isolating
a cow then the horse Takes Over highly
trained the best have agility and style
how important is the connection between
Horse and Rider well to me it's tantamount
of Yellowstone's Cowboys like actor
Corey J Smith are real life cutters
drawing larger than ever crowds
to celebrity competitions yeah
requiring strategy precision and a darn good
horse and it's great for two and a half minutes
it's it's the greatest ride you're ever going to
have that's it a sport rooted in Western culture
of the past gets a moment in the present for
CBS Saturday I'm Janet shamley in Fort Worth
it's really amazing to watch it is it's
very cool I was trying to think of what
to compare it to but there's something very
cool about watching the mirroring that they're
doing while keeping that cattle no I'm so
glad she interviewed Lindy Burch she is a
Phenom a Pioneer in Rodeo and certainly as
national champions of of cutting it's just
it's it's so good this you're still right
and Janet did a nice job yes there you go